dominique monotuka c'est l'avocat du
jeune homme interpellé keziah du ciel
est avec nous en direct sur arte france
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
alors votre client keziah lussier est
toujours hospitalisé à fort-de-france en
mako naissance hier il était toujours
donc là nous sommes au matin en fait lui
dit jeudi
je n'ai pas informations parce qu'il
soit sorti de notre validation et il se
trouve actuellement
alors dans quel état il
hier les informations que j'ai eu c'est
que et se rétablissait au fur et à
mesure il y a eu les analyses
nécessaires
je sais aussi que la douleur en fait
demeure malgré tout les maux de tête
aussi
maintenant ce qui est certain c'est ce
qu'on souhaite c'est que au fur et à
mesure le jeune question se rétablit
alors on voit la vidéo là on la voit à
côté à côté d'où on voit bien votre thé
entier à terre on voit aussi une salle
de 100 à côté de lui qu'est ce qui s'est
passé exactement
alors il s'avère que c'est
essentiellement ce jeune homme qui
d'ailleurs au moment où il va être
interpellé était dans participé à une
manifestation contre cette violence en
fait que subissent les les militants
anti chlordécone
parce que vous savez en fait la cause
initiale en fait la cause c'est ça c'est
en fait
l'impunité en fait de ceux qui nous ont
pas donné genetec parce que je lui j'en
fais partie nous buvons est une maj on
en fait des podiums pas sonné le thème
martiniquaise est empoisonnée et nous
savons en fait les responsables et
finalement il n'y a ni coupable alors
même en fait que tout
procédure légale en été ont été les
jantes et ni coupable et ni réparation
est double d'où l'origine ou en fait les
manifestations hélas dans ce processus
des jeunes en fait on est arrêté et là
en l'occurrence y en a trois qui ont été
arrêtées et mises en garde à vue et
c'est pour cette raison que ce jour ce
jeudi là et bien se trouver en fait
question à côté d'autres hélas
l'occurrence alors qu'ils manifestaient
sans violence avec des slogans et on
sent du tabou puisque comme vous avez là
symboliquement fait le tombeau est d'une
grande importance a fait pour nous ici
en martinique et et voilà et un moment
donné eh bien les alors il y avait
initialement fait les policiers il faut
le savoir les policiers quitté la rangée
et un moment donné qu'est ce qu'on
constate on constate que ils sont
remplacés par pas des pas des gendarmes
ont dit bon et ses gendarmes en fait
mobile en fait qu'ils vont totalement
changé l'ambiance parce qu'un effet ils
vont être agressif et ça va finir en
fait pas la part cette volonté d'un pas
mieux que vouloir récupérer le tabou et
et à partir de là il ya eu ça va je les
fais de ton va monter
et qu'est-ce qui a lui-même d'ailleurs
on le voit sur sur cd vidéo ce qui se
retrouvera devant va aussi les deux bras
podio calmez vous calmez vous et c'est
un moment donné en fait est qu'il prend
conscience en fait qu'il reçoit un
certain nombre de coups de matraque en
fait tout le corps il a dû en fait tu
les payes c'est de se sentir en fait de
cette violence
malgré tout il est attrapé il est jeté à
terre et les frapper vous verrez nulle
part en fait question dans l'édition de
vidéos qui titille qui sont à notre
disposition frappé quelconque en fait le
gendarme en même temps je coupe
appartement mais il ya le
au coeur un terrien de tenir des vidéo
prouvant qu'un genre dame aurait été
frappé par keziah c'est complètement
faux selon vous alors pour moi même en
fait j'ai j'ai eu accès au dossier
j'ai en fait participé à l'audition de
questions durant l'année sa première sa
première garde à vue puisque ça va être
prolongée pourquoi ça va être prolongée
parce que justement pendant les
premières 24 heures de garde à vue
il n'avait aucune preuve en fait il a
fallu en fait une dette que ce soit
prolongée pour que deux coups
apparaissent prétendument aux coups de
pied et ce coup de pied en fait lorsque
ça fera en fait que des photos une photo
en fête ou étendus main il aurait armé
au coup de pied mais on nous montre pas
en fait du rap métal durant la garde à
vue
il n'est pas montrée jeune fille a eu
qui atteint qui est atteint par ce coup
de pied est finalement en réalité à 7
après que apparaît sur sur les réseaux
un prétendu coup de pied que donnerait
en fait question à l'analyse en fait on
voit bien qu'en fait que c'est faux il
ne donne aucun coup de pied à quiconque
en fait d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il a
toujours dit donc
d'ailleurs je vous précise que le
monsieur le procureur ainsi renault au
google à décider par lui-même de saisir
en fait les gipn 1 1 pour justement
qu'est-ce qu'une enquête soit menée afin
de savoir en fait si sept policiers si
ces gendarmes plutôt ont fauté et c'est
pas par hasard si en fait nous procurera
à lui-même en fait constitué cet essai
c'est qu'une telle enquête soit menée
c'est précisément parce que lorsqu on
visualise les vidéos on constate bien
concept c'est jean dame en faute et ses
gendarmes en fait ont frappé ce jeune
homme en fait sans aucune raison valable
et gendarmes ont fait tant en profiter
en de la faiblesse en fait de ce jeune
homme de la partie cité en fait de la
passivité a suscité de ce jeune homme en
fait pour le
pour le frapper poulet ou d'humilier
pour le violenter et ça en fait le poker
est consciente et fonciers un peu d'eux
dont je suis désolé on n'a plus beaucoup
de temps c'est la fin du jt
tu viens ma mort je les remercie
beaucoup votre message est bien passé
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur arte france rappelle que vous êtes
l'avocat de keziah nuissier merci